being that person is that doing this
whole method acting thing and maybe
going off and unfortunately using
substances or or really no no it's not
that's not method
I mean look there are all kinds of
acting techniques and whoever wants to
go that way fine uh but it's idiotic for
an actor to think that in order to play
a meth head that he has to take crystal
meth it's it's like um that's insanity
actors who can play a crystal meth head
talked to crystal meth users and see
what they do but the truth of the matter
is once he sees that or she sees that
what at great actors understand is that
we are everything so therefore you don't
have to take crystal meth you just
surrender to the crystal meth head
within you see actors who play they may
hate child molesters they may hate
murderers they may hate whatever as
people but what they realize at one time
or another in their lives they have evil
to and surrendering to that is the I
mean to me that's the strength of glory
the courage of great actors and we don't
have many of them unfortunately
you